okay hi everyone welcome to a wol from
language design review
session part of a incremental language
development series and we seem to have
several interesting topics today so
let's start off with llm
configuration so we have jul probably
yeah should we take this so here the
idea is that um we have successfully
packaged both um API parameters and top
level parameters that we made use of inm
configuration so you can see here like
for example specifying model temperature
prompts tools for example is something
that could be either you know we have a
custom way to call tools but some apis
have the functions or tool the they
write them but so this is quite quite
flexible and functions can ignore the
the keys they don't know what to do
about complain if it is wrong so it's
kind of working well now how do we
extend this to functions that are not
doing text generation you know we you
know we want I would like to use this in
image syntheti you know to to specify
different uh different model names
different uh different Services y um so
uh if you go open the the extensions
here the so I put here like this is a
lowlevel service provider basically that
that you know I can hook
imti using using this function and this
is implemented with L configuration so
it you know it does the job you you can
you know immediately use E3 and so this
was Works in a branch I can be I can add
this to prototype you can play with this
uh you know it works exactly the same
way
there are few issues here if you open
the design issues which is this is kind
of a mess because this is this is sort
of the parameters being passed to the
model that you would like to default in
some way from the configuration but then
you want to be able to give them
explicitly an image synthesiz right yeah
uh I mean like if you scroll down to
this basically we we have maybe we
identify more here live but the three
main things I have here is like first
one is a slightly annoying naming issue
which is the most minor like this is not
really an llm and like stuff for like
like whisper for audio is not an LM not
not terrible but yeah the the worst is
uh defaults might not make sense so if
you set dollar llm evaluator to
something that might not make sense for
uh for different
tasks yeah because you might want to to
have a model for uh for audio a model
for
images um well maybe we need a more
sophisticated thing maybe we need an
some kind of AI
evaluator I mean you know to in what
sense maybe we need an AI evaluator that
is a superet of LM evaluator and there's
more like the system Services thing
where it's an
association yeah I was thinking about an
association
yeah and then then then we need to
decide if it is by function if it is by
uh no I think it's by function I think
it's going to get complicated because I
think that even in you know for example
llm synthesize can perfectly well should
be able to take an image as a
prompt right
[Music]
so I mean I don't know if that works
right now does
it sorry my my my connection jumped can
can you can you save the question again
LM synthesize take an
image no that that that doesn't work in
top level we are hooking up
now we have added it we have support at
at the service connection level we need
to propagate it to to top level okay so
basically what we've got is you know llm
synthesize is generating
things I
mean the concept that you're just
generating an image like
synthesize my guess is that everything
in the future is
multimodal
MHM right so you might generate an image
with a
caption
um so the only question
is
given well that's the question is what's
the target you know because it could be
the case that that in the future llm
synthesize
you know we'd feed in a picture of a
duck generate a picture of a duck and
out would come the image of a
duck see what I'm
saying yeah I mean that's what that's
what's going to
happen with multimodal llm synthesized
is it
not with M mod you can have both in
input and output uh uh I mean so far
multimodal means that in input you have
images and and text I know but that's
not stay the
cas the thing is who's going
to yeah that that can be that or that
can also be that the API is is using
different models for different tasks
like uh you know could they could try to
offer that they do manually what what we
do s they do automatically what we do
manually now like uh you do one call to
an image generation model and then you
feed back the result into the into the
multimodal text generator to do you know
captioning or or comments about the
image or so the issue right now is this
we have a function image
synthesize um presumably we're going to
have a function audio synthesize before
too long right y
yep why is it llm synthesize and not
text
synthesize huh thanks for the question
it was it was the name original name was
that and then we decided to hold on
using that name because of you know it
might have been something more General
in the future that was the original
discussion so it's a scoped name in a
sense I
see and we don't want llm we don't
really want text function we want llm
function because who knows what that's
doing yeah I mean in in in hindsight it
it was good from this point of view
because we didn't think about multimodal
stuff at the
time
right okay so what functions do we
imagine we're going to have we have
image
synthesize
um we might have video
synthesize we have right now speech
synthesize which hopefully will get
better but I think also speech
synthesize may be able to have some
metadata like
saying make this be you know an angry
Italian male age 35 or something you
know what I'm saying whereas right now
we have voice Styles but I have to
believe that coming
soon will be a description of what we
want am I making sense yeah yeah yeah
yeah this is also the trend like for for
images as well yeah like instead of
having like discret classes you have uh
like both captions generated and and
text to to find the image yeah like as a
as a fuzzy
string so the the trend is is definitely
to to move away from from discrete
things and uh and just have ANM part
that parts to the string I understand
I'm not sure how well that really works
because as you know as we make the
bridge to the symbolic world image
identify going to a a definite entity
that we can then compute with is
worthwhile am I making
sense yeah it's it's application based
you know if you want retrieval then it's
it's useful to be able to say you know
if you're looking in your gigantic list
of of pictures and you want to you want
to find you know that that picture where
you were young with blue trousers on the
beach right that's not a class yeah
that's that that's just it's well then
good that you have a fancy description
but for for the what you say is a
different case is is when you want to to
go on with the computation and do
something with the with specific class
so you're suggesting that there is an
image search for example which is the
thing you just described that's yet a
different use
case yeah I believe that Google is doing
that in Google photos I I don't know
because I I I deactivate that because
I'm afraid
of but I I I've seen that in news I
don't know if anybody here has an
Android phone but yeah
okay yeah is it's similar to like what
is now being discussed with Vector
databases like I do believe they
generate
some
pictures okay so look what we've got
is okay the main issue we have is that
dollar llm
evaluator is set to an llm configuration
right right now yes okay so the
default so I think the the the kind of
the shortterm solution here is to make
llm evaluator be able to be an
association uh yeah it's slightly
annoying because it is it is already you
can already that's a valid syntax and
the the thing is that that thing gets
wrapped in llm configuration and this is
this has been add to be a short hand and
so you have spey always
well I mean yeah we could dis igate
that's that's always a possibility
that's a it's yeah
exactly all is experimental working
progress so if you think that this is
really a much better use case we could
just break the
design just bringing this I don't think
so I don't think it's a better use case
I think it's a hack
I
mean let's
see I mean we could do something like
this see what I'm saying and then the
thing we could still have llm
evaluator which I think is useful right
now I mean you know this this story has
not ended right we we don't know whether
people are going to call it I mean right
now llm is a brand it's just like at
times in the past you know
AI back in the
1980s '70s
whatever everything we do in wolam
language would be
AI today you know
AI had started to mean stuff done with
neural Nets you know if you had a
rule-based system it's just not called
AI I making sense but that's a you know
it's an evolution of the language and I
don't really know where that's going to
land
so also if you look at it what you
propose that's also tricky because um
for example uh text embedding uh text
completion and messaging are all text
based
things uh do they all map to the same
configuration well I think I think we
could we could have this you know we
could have something where it goes into
more
detail you know we can have an
association here where it just says text
you know generic text is blah blah blah
and text completion is this and and so
on I I think we need to experiment a bit
with this but yeah this this is
something that was rooted up today and I
I think I mean this kind of works as a
stop gap for sure and and our llm
services layer gives already a could
um hint about what these Keys should be
yeah because each one of those function
inm Services is collecting different
different apis from different uh um
service connection so I mean each one of
those it symbolizes API calls we do so
we could start with that AI evaluator
rules I'm not super fan of the name but
I don't have
not either but I mean I think
um I don't know what brand other than
quotes AI to
use so okay so then the way this would
work is these various functions which
can use
this could get their AI evaluator rules
which could either be just a pure llm
configuration which means use this for
the default action of this function or
it could be this more elaborate thing
here and then there's a dollar AI
evaluator rules yes exactly I I think
that that that mean as a as a structure
it it makes sense you know we add one
layer of a complexity maybe we can strip
it off before the next release you know
the the you know we we start working
with this see how it I think we leave
the LM evaluator and it it you know
trumps the evalu AI evaluator rules if
it is
provided what about uh AI configuration
object like LM
configuration oh
gosh I just put like a a sketch in
chat which chat the twitch chat yeah oh
okay
I use synthesis in synthesiz
to not not tie it to a specific function
yeah no I think that's
right right and then the automatic at
the end would be the fallback if you're
not if you don't specify something it
would just use what are you sugges that
that we have llm evaluator goes to AI
configuration
no I'm saying L AI evaluator rules goes
to AI
configuration this would just be a
generalization of what we have in for LM
evaluator and LM configuration but we
could use the same symbol this is then a
second level M yes what we what we're
proposing
here is a configuration object which has
another layer
mhm right I don't think that extra layer
will be terrible even in even if it was
just you know a single configuration
knowing that this is a text
synthesis configuration seems useful I
don't I don't disagree this is
reasonable yeah right and that and this
would work for
multimodal you know you could pull
things out that you need for the
service if one service for a multimodal
request one some settings for audio and
some settings for text you would have
it I think it's a reasonable thing to
try let's talk about this the size thing
and so on
right size is something generically set
N I don't think should be generically
set that's up to things like IM in
synthesize to decide what that value
should be oh yeah yeah I mean this is
this is because the the LM Services uses
LM configuration as a second parameter
but this is internal stuff the N is an
argument in image synthetized size is is
image size option and N is an argument
okay but fine but I mean we might want a
default size for a given model and I
don't see any reason why we shouldn't
set an image size in quotes here yeah
yeah in that case yeah in that case
image size yeah of course so it's clear
that is image size because it's it's
confusing otherwise this also solves a
problem that was my my last
um uh
issue with meaning in different but I
think you should still say quotes image
size I don't think you should use the
image size symbol in the association no
I I agree because not our option this is
yeah yeah yeah this will be on the same
syntactical level as the other things it
shouldn't be shouldn't look
different this seems reasonable to me I
mean I'm a little bit
concerned I don't know where this
bouncing ball is going to land and I'm
also concerned that and it might be
worth looking at some of the stuff in
the tutoring project um where you know
Teo has been working on this this vote
of three llms type thing and how we do
that here see what I'm saying I I was
thinking we want something like a llm
graph or llm chain kind of analogist to
what we have for the uh neural Nets
where you can basically Implement like a
voting system where the graph it is like
a tree or it starts out as a tree with
three nodes and then you have another
node where those Connect into that makes
the decision and and each one it takes
the
inputs builds using a template each note
would have a template and then does an
LM synthesize on that right because each
one is going to have to have its own
prompting General yep and potentially
its own uh configuration like different
models and things like
that and it should all run
asynchronously and you know some there
should be a mechanism for cancel ing
certain nodes under certain conditions
well so it's basically
code it's not clear that we need to okay
so what you're saying
is the AI configuration could be a
function I mean I think the design of
those
pieces that
say
uh you get what I mean I I agree I think
it'd be interesting to have some of
those functions
that
says I mean what are we doing it's
instead of llm synthesize it's really a
parallel llm
synthesize followed by in other words
you take three things and then you have
to do something to them you you've got a
list of three things I mean it's it's
code basically yeah you can Define it as
any arbitrary graph where the output of
one can feed into one or more of others
and you can you can build up more comple
complex look at what we're going to run
into here we're going to run into direct
to async evaluate which is basically
doing that I mean for graphs in general
let's look at that in connection with
this okay because I think this this
function may be the function whose whose
functions become
LMS am I making sense yes that does make
sense so let's look at that in a couple
minutes
okay I I have a a short anecdote to
share that may or may not be relevant
which was that last week at JMM somebody
came to the booth and asked how do I
create the the graph of iter I mean I'm
translating a little bit but how did I
create the graph of iterates of 10 x + 2
on z12 without writing any Mathematica
code so I said we turned it to the chat
notebook and we said create the graph of
iterates of 10x mod
12 and uh you know and it just did it it
was very
impressive nice well it's probably
because we have some good examples some
we need to um that it had a chance to
read
um
okay
what is who's who's speaking for vertex
stratify so we have Brad here uh who
authored these and
we yeah I think you've asked um for this
vertex stratify to be brought back to I
because we keep seeing it in in all the
different projects that we do with
directed asyc
graphs okay so remind me what it is what
does it
do it's basically a directed a cyclic
graph is going to have a minimum path
length from its initial vertices to any
vertex in the graph and this vertex
stratify just finds basically finds
those minimum path lengths and writes
the vertices down in a list of lists
where the first list is vertices on the
first level second vertices on the
second wait a minute the general case of
this is the whole foliation thing right
right we've got this is making a
foliation this is making a particular
foliation and we've got these other
functions Nick has this function to make
or maybe it's your function at some
point to
make all
possible sort of this is the
cosmological rest frame that might be
useful to
itti the it's the the main single output
of vertex
stratify is the uh um earliest arrival
foliation I guess you would say it list
the vertices it as early as it possibly
can yeah right but these are all space-
likee hypersurfaces in the sense that
these are all simultaneous everything in
a sublist can be simultaneous is that
correct yeah I think so it's basically
level zero level one level
two and then and how does it relate to
breett First
search um well the bre for search tends
to go level per level it goes to the
first level searches everything second
level searches everything so but so its
ordering its default ordering is so I'm
now forgetting we we've got all these
functions for which are in wfr which we
did in the connection with combinators
for leftmost outer in fact we we've done
that also for tree scanning right the
leftmost outermost etc etc etc thing
haven't we yeah that's not the design we
used but we have tree traversal order
that has depth first breadth first and
leaves first
okay
so this is so what will be the
analog okay so we got a tree traversal
order that so so can I get out of a tree
if I use tree traversal order can I get
out of the tree the list of of of um
nodes in the tree that I will visit in
the order that I will visit
them yeah how do I do that do tree
level okay so if I say random
tree of like 40 or something and now I
say uh tree level that comma tree
traversal
order comma tree traversal order breath
first
I really understand that what am I
seeing here am I seeing these layers
each sub Tree in bread first order if
you just want the data you can say all
goes to
data quotes
data
yep I don't understand
that so this
isn't uh this looks very similar to
vertex stratify the thing that it would
that it's possibly missing is the extra
list structure that divides them into
levels yep so this is the list of all
the vertices at level zero then all of
them at level one then all of them at
level two but it's in a flat list so
just so I understand so so I
mean the point is that in a directed a
cyclic graph we can have merges which we
cannot have in a tree
right
yes which um do the same example but use
leaves
first so this is going by negative
levels and negative level is determined
by your
children the corresponding thing in a
dag is that
your uh positive level is determined by
your
parents right you could if you wanted to
use vertex stratify to get a similar
output you could just do vertex stratify
of the reverse
graph and we can even let's just say
vertify
yep okay so let's just do vertex
stratify here of the um tree graph of
that first graph right well make sure
that you get directed edges though well
do we get directed edges from tree grath
I don't
remember it should have a directed Edge
option just like um yeah I I
would yeah it's directed by
default
okay okay so I'm officially confused
here well it's because the oh I see
because the node names you might if you
do vertex replace on the tree graph you
can get get it simplified I think you
just want the first of whatever yeah
right right right
right oh you'd have to map that on level
two
okay so now all that we see comparing
this vertex stratify output to the other
earlier tree level thing is that there's
a random disordering per level which
makes makes
sense because there's no criteria for
vertex stratify being applied to try and
um straighten out the vertices in any
particular sublist any so far any order
is is okay whereas with a tree there is
a definite ordering Brad does it just
put the vertex names in canonical
order it it might I don't know I haven't
I haven't given that much thought to it
okay so I mean that's something we could
discuss now if there's uh some
particular order to well I mean for a
tree there is but not for a graph right
no for a graph there could be too
because the the graph object itself in
its vertex list has a canonical order so
try to test that if we just do the the
vertex list of tree graph and see if
they're appearing in order vertex list
is kind of the closest thing to vertex
stratify yeah I get it
oops
373 oh yeah
okay you have to map first at that I
think first on to this
yeah so now we can check okay it looks
like 11 is first and then oh so there 11
is
before yeah so I'm confused with this
this is probably in like depth first
order well in other words you've put a
you've put an ordering on the vertices
when you create the tree graph and the
question is what ordering did you put
and you might have put a depth first
ordering which might or might not be
right no I don't think it would be depth
first but it could be Discovery first
like this algorithm is going to go I'd
have to who's whose algorithm I'm not
talking about your algorithm I'm talking
about this is uh um Ian's algorithm here
yeah for I'd have to check but I think I
put them in depth first order so that
the um Branch order turns out correct I
think that whatever order it is it it
was just so that the uh tree
visualization has the branches in the
correct order I see it's it's sensitive
to the vertex and Edge ordering remember
okay so okay so what we've got here is
you know we've got this directed ayclick
graph and you know we're going to we're
going to presumably we're we we are not
going to
have a separate dag
construct which hopefully we don't need
and that our dags are still basically
just graphs right we're not going to
have a special dag
object right yeah okay so now I could
see a use for a dag object that has
ordered branches but it's not necessary
for this functionality I don't
think look we need graphs with ordered
ordered you know with
ports right same deal basically yeah
yeah we we were talking about that last
time we talked about directed a cyclic
evaluate too okay so I mean that's the
thing we need and do we have Charles
here or anybody from the graphs group
Charles was invited he declined to come
but we can poke him if we need to okay
well I think we should time to
poke anybody I think since we already
have um dags as our current unordered
graph objects I don't think that the um
grass with ports or ordered branches
should be a prerequisite for this
functionality no it's not it's not it's
not there's still a definite order it's
just the yeah okay so to
me
um I know if if if we can poke Nick see
if Nick is around that would also be
helpful because I think I think you know
we we've got this function that
generates all possible foliations right
yeah so does mine and just to zoom back
to when we were arguing about this last
time there was a discrepancy between
what Nick did and what I did and I can
only prove what I've
done okay well okay so for example here
I think I have
um okay so that's a depth first
ordering right that's a depth first scan
and somewhere here I've got many
different possible foliations
Right makees sense
guys yep that's a dag and that's its
many
foliations and you know to
me where's
foliations uh where does it set it okay
graph
foliations okay so this
is basically all all partitions that
respect the order from the exactly
direct yes but but I've investigated
that closely and I don't know if that's
what's being produced because vertex
stratify if we go look at the wfr page
we can see there's another usage that's
not just the default usage and it's
going to give you all all of the things
and we did Nick and I did not get the
same
results okay where's the where's the non
well scroll scroll up
there returns a comprehensive set of
stratifications with at most and
additional levels per stratification
cu the okay the other thing you can do
is like look this stratification here
has four levels to it but if I say that
I'm willing to add one additional level
then I'm going to get let's just try
that and see what
happens so
first this this example that we're
looking at
there yeah just copy that if we copy
that whole
thing yeah okay but I mean there so
there's a graph here
okay and then just extract the vertex
stratifi g0 and and replace that whole
statement there the whole labeled
statement so that we can just see what's
the output of the function
is
right okay so add add the extra argument
comma zero and see if that changes
anything
I don't expect that it would says that
there's only an extra layer right
because there's only now like change
that that's a rigid graph there but now
if we change this to
one then all of a sudden there's a bunch
of different
options
right although now that I'm looking at
it I don't know if it should be an
option should it be an option to put a
blank on the first level probably or to
leave a blank anywhere probably
not I think it might need to be I mean
Nick is the expert on on what we've done
with I
mean well do I get do I get to be an
expert too or is it just
Nick you can be an expert too Brad thank
you because I've written three or four
of these blog posts now so I know I know
I know I know but I mean we've we've
done
uh you know we've had different um oh
when you say Nick you mean Nick with no
C that is correct okay that I was
confused for a little while there but
now I understand I I am not an expert in
this
now
um hold on one second
guys
hi again okay
so all right so treat your traversal
order you know the defin definition of
which of these foliations you get which
reference
frame is well let let's take a
look
here at directed a cyclic evaluate
because I think it's also related to
this I mean but basically what we what
we're doing
here well actually there's one for
vertex stratify if I remember correctly
there's one interesting neat example
that's worth looking
at it's on on the page there yeah saying
like certain if you have a graph like
this this graph that we just looked at
when we did
g0 it it only had one result why is that
because the entire graph is is what I
called a rigid subgraph and there are
other graphs like I guess this one here
is an example where if you try to do
vertex stratify zero then you get a
bunch of different options because
there's a vertices that are floating
around there and they can be perturbed
up or down a
level yes I understand I mean it's it's
like it's simultaneity surfaces it's
like you can sometimes have only one
possible choice of simultaneity surface
or you can have multiple different
reference Vibes with different choices
of which s which events are simultaneous
yeah and I think the the use case for
having these um for extending the time
access it with regard to directed a
cyclic evaluate is like maybe we're
doing a parallel calculation where we
want to evaluate vertex functions all at
the same time but we're um constrained
by the number of cores that we have
available yeah yeah
right let's let's zoom out here okay so
the function vertex stratify I don't
know if it's the right name um it's not
a terrible
name
uh
is you know it has a default potentially
which is this bre first traversal or
this cosmological rest frame or this you
know everything as quickly as you can
kind of thing right
yeah um there is also a depth first
version of this
presumably is depth first defoliation
though no not necessarily but you
can illustrations on tree traval order
um first and leaves first are obviously
foliations but depth first
has the level sets like inside each
other right so the question is can we
label the
foliations and this is kind of like you
know one thing we've got a can iCal
foliation which is this uh everything as
quickly as you can foliation right yeah
we might have another one that's
canonical which is everything as slowly
as you can yeah yeah that's true I think
Danny made that point back when we were
talking about this okay so then then
we've got all of the other reference
maybe Brad you know the answer is the
everything as slowly as you can is that
what you would get from vertex stratify
of the reverse graph yeah I think so
probably okay that'd be my guess which
is your leaves first I think
yes okay and are those the only two
foliations for
trees since they have a unique parent
each node well it depends on the
rigidity
thing so some like if there's a short
branch and a Long Branch there for the
foliation the short Branch can get
permuted forward I see yeah okay all
right so let let's
then to me look I think vertex Stratus
by its default seems clear and it seems
like a good function to have now the
question is how do you get the other
foliations out of it okay and this
reminds me a lot of find
path and find path by
default gives it still gives a list
right find path still gives am I am I
right if I say find path
of this thing or this thing here right
if I say find
path of that comma I don't know uh 3
comma 8 for example I see it'll give a
sublist
there I'm just concerned about I mean if
I say find shortest path here because
you can also do all right yes you can so
there if I say
all comma all
here there's only one of
them no that does not seem right to me
let's go three comma six that doesn't
Seemy how long your PA should be yeah
yeah in I think you have to write
infinity or double yeah okay
fine fine so in the case of these fol
ations the question is what are the
selectors that we want for these
foliations because they very quickly get
very long and and Nick has this include
permutations are not what is the
relationship between graph graph
foliations is kind of so if I take this
and I
say graph foliations of this let's say
include permutations to
false that's only one foliation right
that correct I think that's correct yeah
that right maybe we should try the other
graph example where that's non- rigid
from the wfr page because that will that
one will probably which one that one
right there this one here yeah I think
seed Rand if you get the g0o there it
should be
fine
just this
yeah
okay so now we take
that ah not the right
thing okay and can we compare that to
vertex stratify with the extra zero
argument you've got you've got the
analog of include permutations to true I
think oh well let's test that and just
look at the length of those two lists
and see if they're the
same there's also another property
for whether you can allow to put a
vertex in
it in one of the
certifications so it's called bundle I
called it bundle foliations it also
might counter to how many of them there
how many did we get over here it may be
the same I think it's the same pretty
close yeah okay so that's good yep
okay we need if we're really serious
about this we need to do a a detailed
double check making sure that Nick and I
have the same definitions that we get
the same numbers every time yeah yeah
yeah I agree I agree
so I think what we need to
do I don't understand Nick's bundle
thing
but this permutations thing is is useful
that that's a useful and probably by
default we don't want to generate all
the permutations
we just want to generate the canonical
order because most of the time the big
problem is going to be you know because
anytime you can permute any of these in
any way you want can't
you each one of these space likee
surfaces can be can have arbitrary
ordering
right well if I guess if they get off in
different disconnected subgraphs maybe I
don't
know
Nick
do you mean within each of the foliation
you can permute vertices in any order
yes yeah that's yeah right so so I don't
think that's what mine is doing
though well I don't know what it's doing
but it yours was nice and fast that
was um well they noted with they they
always sorted with an exfoliation
statification
you why how how what are all of these
include permutations just means that we
also get 869 is that correct in
here no I don't think so no what does
include permutations
mean it's it's a Well I can't really
remember it's a algorithmic thing what
they actually do when you consider when
you put your new vertex in
affiliation right because you always
have a choice and you can do it like in
all possible way so in the first can
okay so I don't know if there's a
trivial transformation from this to the
all permutations then we probably just
want by default to return that this
thing and if all you do is to say you
know permutations of each of these
things I'm not sure but but okay it's
not it's not that trivial okay fine fine
all right
well okay but clearly we need both the
canonical foliation and we need a way to
generate either a selected set of per of
foliations for example example we could
do the same thing that we do with fine
path of say give us a thing which is
stratifying into some number of of of
strata if you understand what I'm
saying that will be a way of because
clearly there is
a there is presumably a stratum where
everything is being done
separately yeah if the number of strata
is the same as the number of vertices or
something right but right but I'm saying
that as's a way to select between
because we're going to get very large
numbers very even a very small graph
we're going to get very large numbers
and the useful thing is going to be the
canonical
stratification and other ones that are I
mean I don't know how we can say what
what other ones are going to be useful
get what I'm saying yeah I I think what
you're saying is that we need to put
some time into thinking about how to
thin the results out because there are
going to be too many results but I I
think that a possible approach would be
to model what we do with find path where
you give an argument that says what the
number of of stratifications the number
of uh the number of slices in the
foliation should be well that that's
that is already the second argument to
vertex
stratify but it's a different something
Rel yeah it's different conven same
idea right but but that that I don't
think that's going to solve the thin I
don't see how that solves the thinning
problem for the thinning problem we will
like have have to specify maybe
properties that each level needs to
satisfy or something well PL so which is
similar to the depth first breadth first
type story I think that depth first and
bread first will play into a resolution
of this problem yeah because there's EXT
let me let me just point out this
problem is the problem that I've been
yakara about for like three years which
is this problem of what are reasonable
reference frames see what I'm saying and
we've talked about this a bunch of times
you know there are ones that are deeply
fragmented there are ones that look like
you know that look like this which is a
weird reference frame right that's a um
well that that's just an ordering but
you know we we could have something
where we have well down here we have
something where some of these are very
weird reference frames see what I'm
saying of what's
simultaneous am I making
sense and there's some that are more
reasonable okay so all right so we want
to have vertex stratify the name is not
terrible can I suggest graph levels
because the everything as fast as
possible and everything as slow as
possible exactly correspond to positive
and negative levels in an expression or
a
tree we'll consider that graph levels as
possibility graph strata
maybe maybe I mean there's also the
foliation term all right but I I don't
know
which is the right thing um uh okay
let's go on to directed a cyclic
evaluate which I think is a very
interesting function we have Charles as
well
now okay all
right so the basic point of directed a
cyclic evaluate
is there are values coming in
from
sort of the leaf
nodes and at each non-leaf
node there is a
function that combines those Leaf nodes
is that
correct um yeah I might say it backwards
that the values are coming from the root
nodes
yeah okay but but but but this is
essentially the same thing as an
expression
tree um this
example of course this works for
dags right so the point is
that in an expression
tree this is evaluation of an expression
the point is that there can be shared
common sub Expressions which makes it a
dag
right in the general case
yeah okay
right I'm not quite sure what all of
this is I mean these these are just uh
the highlighting is the values coming in
and the frames or the functions at the
nodes I think buing usage
basically the latest thing we've used
directed a cyclic evaluate for is to
um we had these game graphs that Andrea
and I made and we figured out a way to
take the entire game graph and prune it
down into a minimal version using
directed acylic evaluate so that we got
from like
having a proof that the second player is
going to win this game maximally it
takes 10,000 vertices but then you could
prune it down to only
okay and
um that the the Restriction of directed
a cyclic evaluate is that the vertex
function is the same on every
vertex and another one is that it does
not the the order of
inputs is not not critical or not paid
attention to by when evaluating these
vertex functions so so this is
essentially
I mean to
me the obvious name is something like
graph
evaluate or uh Ian and I have been
talking about this last night maybe
propagate vertex weights because one of
the main design changes that needs to be
made from what's at the wfr right now is
that will probably just return the
vertex weights whether that's as may
maybe as an
association
so
to me propagate vertex weight sense okay
because really what's happening it's not
it's not that's incomprehensible nobody
will understand that use but kind of
like vertex weight
fold right but graph evaluate it may be
misleading because we cannot in this
case uh
do undirected graphs and we also can't
even do cyclic graphs because the s we
don't have uh
any idea of what to do if the if no I
know welcome to close time like curves I
mean you know it that's the you know
it's the fter of Science Fiction of what
happens with in a universe with closed
time like cves that's that's what we
have when we have Cycles on the graph we
don't have a notion of time we don't
have a way to stratify
time that make sense function may be
related to s more than just like
evaluating or folding something I had
this physics example when you
essentially use it to evalate Puff
integral version on a graph and it just
the same is basically the you can use it
to compute all the Puffs and sum them
over well so you're saying okay hold on
let me just understand what's happening
here so the most obvious thing would be
um
a you know a function
f applied at the function f applied to
the
weights
oops Yeah you just had that above vertex
weight
fold of f
comma
now I don't understand at the
nodes that so what would happen is the
nodes the intermediate nodes wouldn't
have weights on them initially no the
the way that directed directed a cyclic
evaluates usage is set up it needs a
graph initial values and the vertex
function and the vertex function has a
what what this basic example is showing
here is vertex function it actually gets
a little bit of extra information in
addition to just the the preceding
vertex weights okay but what I'm
suggesting is this
the I'm suggesting the
following vertex weight fold of this
comma graph assumes that the graph has
already had vertex weights added on its
leaves yeah I don't what's that an to
Bally fully weighted graph theun weights
the second argument for the vertex
function and directed I cyclic evaluate
is The Edge weights and the third
argument is the edges we need Edge
weights for probability
calculations yeah so the function that
we're putting there first if we make it
too simple then the then the then this
vertex weight fold if that's what you're
going to call it it won't be able to
calculate everything we need it to yeah
fine fine so you're saying that that
function is going to fill in at every
node okay
so it's taking input to F
is I don't quite understand why why the
input to F isn't just a list of edges
it's the parent vertex weights the
parent Edge weights
and the parent
edges but if it was just the edges they
have the edge weights in them don't
they usually I'm trying to understand
just edes can contain tags you have to
query for the weights separately
yes where are the weights
stored the weights have to be
in globally for the graph is that
correct yeah
correct me if I'm wrong but I don't
think direct today cyclic evaluate
actually uses the vertex weights and
Edge weights from the graph
it's it's not but it could it's not
currently but it could how how do you
put them into the graph remind me how
that
works like any kind like any other
option like vertex labels Edge labels
you just say
ver mean if I just say if I just say
graph a goes to B B goes to
C and then I say vertex
weights goes to one two
three weight
singular okay how do I find those vertex
weights is it annotation value or
something like that yeah yeah Charles
can you say please annotation value of a
Gra then second argument vertex
weight is Charles here um yes I'm
here okay but so the vertex weights are
stored as a metadata to the graph
they're not stored sort of
microscopically granularly inside the
graph
correct um why the I mean all the
property anything which is not
topological structure uh annotation
Associated to the graph not granularly
what is the input form of the graph on
395 well the input form doesn't
represent anything doesn't represent how
we store right we we build the in form
but because you ask you ask for okay
okay but so the basic point is that in
your folder here what you're doing is
you're taking at every node down here
you are
taking the weights of the edges that
come
in but more importantly the weight of
the
vertices coming that came in from
here that were evaluated so
far
yep what about the names of the
vertices uh that that is handled through
a third argument and that can also be
important because if you have the name
especially if you have the name of the
vertex that you're on then you can start
it's a little cumbersome but you can
start switching the function that you're
evaluating and we have to do that for
some of the games proofs yeah okay okay
evaluate a different function for player
one and player two okay so the the
function f needs to take can I just say
the third argument is the edges and from
that you can get the parent vertices and
the current vertex yes I understand okay
so the f is taking
the incoming the vertex
weights the vertex The Edge
weights which should be equal in number
to the vertex weights and the edges
themselves right
yes
well that's not
crazy so for example if we want to do
probability calculations we would be
that function for
probabilities uh we would simply be
adding probabilities right so it would
be a total of hash two is that
correct no no because because
you have you're going to have the The
Edge weights are for the probability
usage is just going to be dividing by
the outre degree of a particular vertex
but you're still going to have some
value on the vertex so you've got to
multiply the value that's on the vertex
by The Edge weights and so I think that
that's probably going to be a DOT
product of number one and number
two
yeah and I'm okay so is that right that
it's the vertex it's literally
that yeah
probably as long as you have the edge
weights set correctly in the vertex
weights
too
okay starting to favor graph weight fold
since we have vertex and Edge
weights yes it shouldn't be vertex
weight
right well but okay here's here's the
question then are the The Edge weights
going to get
Rewritten because the vertex weights are
being written Lively but like with this
probability usage you have to put in all
of the edge weights and they never get
edited they never get changed so for
that reason I'd say keep it vertex we F
because that's the only thing that's
getting Rewritten
yeah well
so but then this will return a graph is
that correct in in which the in which
the vertex weights have been Rewritten
I'd rather that it didn't do that
because then we've got all sorts of
extra overhead time for the users
inputting the annotations and then when
they get the graph back extracting the
annotations okay
on from a practical point of view I'd
rather just be able to input the initial
values as an argument like you would
with Nest or like you would with the
extra okay but that we can do that we
can do both cases right so this here
would return the
graph and I need to do something here so
hold on a second
um but I don't think we can have two
output forms can we well we can if we
have a third argument I mean so if we
say the graph and then we have init here
where in knit how do we know what order
a knit is in how do we know what the
leaf nodes are that we're going to give
or the root nodes that we're going to
give the init for root the root nodes
have no in component I understand that
but what order are they in it's a big
mess to figure out which ones they are
no the order doesn't matter at all the
order the first thing that vertex weight
fold would do is a calculate a foliation
or the stratification once it does then
it knows how to proed through and
calculate all the values okay here's the
problem that I have in this graph okay
we don't know for this inet we don't
know
what the you know it has you know five
inputs here right y I have no idea in
what order those inputs right yeah so
just put it in as a list of rules or as
an association okay so you're saying
that that init could be V1 goes to
weight one etc etc etc I'm not saying
that it could be that I'm saying that
the version that's published on wfr
already is that okay all right okay so
that's that's giving there's a question
of if it should be a list of rules or a
function and I think maybe we could have
some flexib strong arguments function is
good Association is good too list of
rules good I think that the list of
rules is sensible because the graph is
of finite size
you can always generate this
function by just saying by mapping it
over vertex list of graph
yep but in the case where you give that
a
nit then to me the output given that
you've had that a nit then the output
could be a corresponding list could it
not yeah yeah I agree with that yeah and
if you don't give the inet the output is
the
grath if that's good for everybody else
it works for me
I think it's
sensible so you'd have if in the two
argument case it would need to be a
weighted a vertex and Edge weighted
graph exactly and then it would
overwrite the vertex weights or maybe by
doing this operation I think right now
directed a cyclic evaluate uses the
vertex names as the default um vertex
weight if no weight if no weight is
satis is spe yeah that's fine I mean it
can do something like that that's fine I
think that's a little weird because
because the vertex names are unique
which is a kind of a weird thing to
do I think it would be sensible to just
initialize all vertex was to one
probability calculations because that
seems sensible that seems more sensible
to me that the default is vertex weights
are one if no weights are
specified well why not zero Charles what
does vertex weight go to automatic do is
it different in different functions I
think like the find path functions has
default weight is one no technically all
the weight always
one
okay same with Edge
weights Charles Edge weights um actually
is the other way
around uh in general the edge with
always the edge weight are one the Vex
weight we don't require them to have a
specific value so we don't have any case
where we actually need a specific value
or set up a default value for the Vex
weight okay well so we can pick one here
I think it's a reasonable thing to
do um the dot product would just return
puff count by default which is
great so F being the dot product if f is
dot I don't even know we might have to
do hash one hash two there all right I
think we got a plan here I think I need
to run along here but if is there
anything else we can cover right now
this looks like a good plan and I think
we should start
off vertex weight fold is not my
favorite name but let's start by with
that
name right seem reasonable yep thank you
and uh I think it's a great
function and very useful particular if
people can understand it and and then I
think we've also got a plan for whatever
vertex stratify or vertex levels or
graph levels whatever it should be
called yeah Danny linked to the
Wikipedia article for graded post
set we're not going to call it that
might be related terminology there it's
absolutely related terminology I mean as
is foliation as is reference frame as is
you know traversal order yeah there
there were a bunch of terms in there
that that what I was getting at they
call them ranks among other
things each
level I also noticed that colel um
thanks um this is also not a huge
extension as far as I can tell from
topological
sort I never remember what topological
sort does well it gives a sort a sorting
that's compatible with the
grading that
um sorting of the nodes compatible with
the grading given by verch stratify for
example I see well that's a good good
connection to make so it's possibly just
a catenation of verch
stratify that's the it looks like to me
yeah the default vertex
stratify I mean it it's a concatenation
of a Vertex stratification whether it's
the one in that particular function I
don't know yeah because there's a
possibility to rearrange per
level well why is yeah why is two so far
up
there I don't know this looks wrong I
mean something is different we have to
understand this there's not there's not
always a unique topological
sorting right so this may be a
particular fol that's correct and not
the one that we're picking by default
which is probably wrong and we probably
should rethink topological sort for this
case so whatever traversal order we use
for stratify we should also probably be
able to use for topological sort I I
would be careful on that uh I mean
Charles probably can comment but I'm
guessing it was written for efficiency
and we shouldn't force it to do
something different if that's the case
fine but but this is this is a similar
operation to this stratify operation yes
very much so well I mean the fact that
there are 17 different things that all
lead to the same end result of wanting
the stratify operation means we need the
stratify operation and it's no surprise
then that it's showed up in a bunch of
stuff Nick and Brad and I have done but
topologic s probably also appear in more
things so it's a matter of point of
view whatever I mean I my point is that
this General operation of you know
forming and ordering of vertices by some
kind of foliation type thing seems like
a generic operation and we should have
that function which is what we were
concluding anyway because graph users
will be gratified that their dags can be
stratified say that a few times fast all
right well if I can make one more
suggestion if we're willing to explore
the different vertex
stratifications maybe there's a chance
to put an extra argument on a
topological sort and do something
similar there yes I agree I agree that's
what I was suggesting that it should
agree with with what we do here all
right I think we got a path forward so
to speak talk see you all
soon bye
bye